what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Tiff 2022 I have the
team behind the people's Joker here and
I mean this from the bottom of my heart
this is a one of a kind production that
is so special for so many reasons
there's no way we're gonna have time to
get to everything but know that I feel
that way okay I have a feeling you're
gonna get asked this a lot at the
festival but when it's a festival
Premiere a lot of our audience does not
know what your movie is just yet so can
you give us a brief synopsis of the
people's Joker for sure the people's
Joker is a illegal queer coming-of-age
comic book movie about an unfunny
transgender clown named Joker who starts
an illegal comedy theater in a town
called Gotham City that didn't pique
someone's interest there's something
wrong with them before digging into the
movie itself I wanted to know a little
more about your background beer because
I know you've worked with Tim and Eric
before and they are our one-of-a-kind
creators themselves so how has working
with them influence the filmmaker you
are now and want to become in the future
well when I was when I was in like film
school I really I was obsessed with
experimental film and like particularly
like Kenneth anger and Maya Darren and
stuff and I think even back then in my
head I was like this is what I'll do for
a living I'll be like an experimental
filmmaker and I'll you know and like I
would never have made a living off of
that and I discovered Tim and Eric like
around that time and it was like this is
the closest I can get to it these are
the really pushing the medium forward
with like analog and VHS and stuff like
what a such a great environment to uh
come up in and like learn all the stuff
that I had to learn to ever pull off any
of the stuff we did in this movie
they're one of the most traumatizing
interviews I've ever done I knew it I
knew it I knew what I was in for when I
agreed to sit down for a 20-minute
on-camera interview but it was literally
20 minutes of the two of them pretending
to bake bread under their hat and I'm
just sitting there and trying to ask my
thoughtful questions about filmmaking
well there was your mistake
I've learned my lesson if we ever uh If
We Ever Meet Again I will be breaking uh
bread under my house I like to think
they've softened a little bit so
hopefully maybe you'll be able to have a
real conversation with them if you see
them again one can dream one can dream
all right Bree I want to phrase this
right I heard that you commissioned a
found footage remix of Tom Phillips uh
Joker movie what exactly does that mean
and what inspired that great question
Perry
um we were talking about specifically it
was when Joker was coming out and Todd
Phillips had said something about
pivoting for making comedy to making
drama and Barry and I had worked
together quite a bit and had never even
come close to being able to do what Todd
Phillips had done in comedy so we were I
was I was salty I was salty about that
comment
I wanted to see what would happen if we
just sort of clowned around with Joker
uh so I believe it was like over the
lunch table one day uh we threw it out
and then I then mowed Vera 12 and we
were Off to the Races and here we are
and I had a typical Tiff story I'd never
like gotten a commission for anything
before like nobody's ever like like I've
been paid to do artistic things but like
I've never it was the most I've ever
felt like an artist even though like
she's my friend
and it was twelve dollars but yeah
that's how it started I feel like that
receipt is something you should print
out and save isn't it like a like a
Superstition especially when you get
your first job ever and you get your
first paycheck you're supposed to save
it for good luck I would like to also
add that I did send another twelve
dollars last week when Vera finished the
film so the total is 24. we weren't
skimping angel investor
you know I don't I can't reveal what the
budget was but it was more than twenty
four dollars so there's something about
that bookend that makes me very happy I
love hearing about how collaborators
find the right partners and come
together so how did all of you meet to
begin with we met at absolutely at Tim
and Eric's production company and Brie
was a writer on numerous shows there
Nate and I have been making stuff
together
as long as we've known each other really
yeah like we did web series we used to
do stuff out of uh
like a public access station called
Highland Park TV in LA and then uh yeah
we clicked right away like I mean I'm
I'm I'm
um
you know I'm I'm kind of a submissive uh
timid person I'm I'm very intense but uh
I I don't often find people that I can
like mock to their face yeah and we
quickly realized oh we have a good
report he's like I could just make fun
of him I'm a great sub yeah he's a good
sub he's like a Bottom's bottom is that
that's what I always used to tell people
about him
um yeah I mean yeah
should we start baking bread
[Applause]
this wasn't in my media training sorry
it was to the point too where I was like
really excited about this project like I
like when you said you were doing it I'm
like I gotta find a part I'm a comic
book guy like I'm trying to think like
oh should I like pitch myself as
Commissioner Gordon or something you're
like yeah duh you're the pain yeah it
literally wrote the part for you you're
obviously penguin you look like you look
like a I mean sorry he is allergic to
fish though so that's true
so you get the idea to make a movie it's
not really a traditional green light
scenario because you did it yourselves
but what was the first moment where you
went from thinking we want to make this
movie too it's actually gonna happen and
we're gonna finish it too I mean it
really was when like when the commission
was was you know presented you know I
started making like a found footage
Joker movie like using Todd Phillips
movie and Batman Forever and you know
60s Batman and kind of making this big
like almost everything is terrible style
mashup of it and and really like in that
process and and also just thinking about
these characters is like you know we're
it's shoved down our throats all the
time they're like these are the modern
myths and like oh it's so important
which is like really just propaganda
created by our government so that like
Marvel movies keep getting made but
really thinking about it is like if this
these are like modern myths like myth is
about exploring coming of age and like
you know coming into being so like it
really all the themes just kind of
presented themselves and I I brief said
this the other day and like put it best
like from every step of the way we were
just having fun and not really obsessing
about consequence which is for me my
therapist is very proud of me for that
uh but yeah like I think that's why it
really worked like we just followed the
joy and yeah so incredibly refreshing to
hear that so given how you made I feel
like we always talk about like a movie
like is a script and then it changes
during production and then it changes
during the edit I feel like that isn't
this is an extreme example of that so
what would you all say is the biggest
difference between how you envision this
film turning out day one of shooting to
what we get in the Final Cut of it
I mean for me it was just like
your brain works differently that like
you visualize this stuff in like this
intense and insane way uh where I was
like you're like okay so we're gonna do
this like shot and like we're gonna be
walking then it's gonna like do
Reservoir Dogs type Styles panning and
stuff I'm like okay so what does that
mean for me to do and you're like take
one step forward turn slightly to your
right okay
and then it looks awesome like it looks
amazing I think you like because we we
had a work in progress screening with
some friends and family and crew and
stuff and it was particularly like
really nice to watch Nate's face because
I could tell like while he was watching
the movie like oh Nate didn't think this
was gonna be good
they thought this was gonna just be like
something maybe 20 of our friends would
watch you know like smelly Warehouse
somewhere in Highland Park and yeah I
know oh it blew my mind and it was like
same thing like to toot both your horns
like I got this script and I was like I
this
is like a cave painting like I don't
know what it is like and it's just like
and then like you know think about
Batman Forever This is you tooting our
horn yeah that was like the worst dude
I've ever heard in my life
I don't think I've ever heard someone
describe a script as a cave painting
before
we're gonna talk about this later
I hope Werner Herzog is not in the
elevator on the way down because we're
gonna have a fight oh my God I have so
many questions you just brought up that
you did a work in progress screening and
that part of the process always
fascinates me because it is important to
share your movie and to be able to take
notes but it is also equally as
important to know when notes should not
be taken because they'll tamper with
your original Vision how is it finding
that balance
I mean you know with this it actually
was really easy because the whole Spirit
of this production was I'm going to
break every single rule that I was
taught in comedy in presenting my gender
in in like what we're told superhero
movies should be about so like really
when I would get a note that would make
me go like
ah it would actually be really easy for
me to go like no thank you actually
we're gonna do this and I mean there's a
lot of things in the movie that have
you know like Batman in the movie is not
a great guy he's he's like a fascist
billionaire who uh is you know kind of a
download download gay and also has some
other skeletons in his closet and like
that has really rubbed some people the
wrong way and I think that was even
something we were kind of nervous about
approaching but
um yeah I mean like I I really miss I
miss dangerous comedy and dangerous like
films that don't take cheap shots at
people so yeah I think that was just
kind of the the Mantra from the
beginning
I need to ask about the illegal nature
of it I liked your answer to this in the
Press notes but but really because I
know that you know like parody law and
all those types of rules it's like very
gray area kind of stuff so like what
what x actually is the illegal nature of
this movie is it truly illegal to the
point this is very businessy but to the
point where getting a distributor might
be a scary situation because can they
distribute it I I this film can be 100
distributed it is completely protected
under fair use and copyright law in like
uh parity law
um the only thing that like makes it
weird in both of those categories is
nobody's ever taken you know characters
and IP and really like personalized it
in this way so I think that's the thing
that really kind of makes it seem a lot
maybe more dangerous than I actually
think it is and I mean I get it look I
put a legal comic book movie on the
poster but that was just to get your
butts in the seats you know yeah
um but yeah no I mean like there's
there's there's literally no reason for
any
anybody to worry I think about like
legal repercussions with this and and
we've really without getting into it
we've we've gone really far to ensure
that we could do this I wouldn't have
spent two years of my life uh
I I probably wouldn't have spent two
years of my life making it an actually
illegal Joker movie if you could give
one actionable piece of advice to anyone
out there who winds up getting getting
inspired by your movie and wants to put
a similar Twist on another uh popular
film franchise out there what would it
be do it I got away with it and so can
you yeah absolutely no respect for
corporate IP
thank you yeah yeah I mean there's how
many artists contributed to this over a
hundred yeah like it's it's it's crazy
like from all over the globe I mean
really just like pool your resources and
I mean this took me so long to learn
even after like 10 years of working in
TV and stuff it's just like don't wait
for somebody to tell you that it's okay
to make the movie that you've been like
trying to like that you've been aching
to make for a long time like just go out
there and just do it to learn a little
more about the process of what it took
to make this uh I'll go your way with
this what can you share about the green
screen experience and maybe even
specific advice you could give to
someone out there who is like I can't
shoot something on green screen it's too
difficult I mean it's pretty pretty
bananas just because like a it's like it
taught me a little bit about trust even
though we've worked together for on tons
of stuff but like this was a different
thing and also we shot it in the middle
of the pre-vaccine pandemic and so like
trusting that the makeup artist putting
my prosthetic on also was is taking you
know all of that stuff the whole thing
just felt trust like if I trust and then
look what paid off I'm here talking to
you with two bucks and and yeah like I
mean it really was just more so than
anything I've done just like you said it
was about friendship and I think I even
told Nate I need you there for the
entire shoot he didn't stay for the
entire he got paid for the entire job
you didn't stay for the entire shoot but
regardless it was really sweet when I
said uh I need you there because you are
my family and that really was kind of
the the vibe I think I mean everybody
says that but it really was I mean it
was a scary time to be alive let alone
making anything and yeah it was yeah I
feel like making something Powers anyone
through that scary time to be alive if I
couldn't make things during that period
of lockdown I don't I don't know how
healthy I would be now no and honestly
this movie wouldn't exist without that
like the early lockdown because I was no
longer getting hired for anything
because believe it or not uh when covet
hit people didn't really uh people
weren't like oh we need alternative
comedy right now um yeah it was like not
an essential service randomly yeah
I am going to try to get my student
loans forgive forgiven for it but um
yeah no I mean it so it really was just
like
we have the time to finally really
devote to something like this one
specific person I wanted to ask how they
got involved Bob Odenkirk he's on the
brain right now at dummy day oh yeah no
I mean so that's still so surreal
because
I I mean so we Bob Lagoon was always in
the script and it was always like a
question of like who could play this
part because it also wasn't really like
a well-developed role it was just I want
this weird Bob Lagoon character in it it
was like what famous Bobs do I kind of
know and one was Odin Kirk because I
worked with him on birthday boys but I
was very nervous to ask him because a I
was a I was pretending to be a different
gender at the time and B he always used
to get my name wrong he's the nicest man
I've ever worked with
but like so I I actually called high
Decker and was like can you cash in one
of your I'm sure you have a limited
amount of favors with him left but and
um he hooked it up and I had a call with
Bob and it was like literally like a
half hour phone call where we talked
about the part and it was really cool
and he was very
um you know he listened to to me ramble
about you know all my highfalutin ideas
about this illegal movie and um and you
know his only request was you know like
you know I'll I'll do it I want to do it
I think it's great I think you're great
but like just make me look kind of
[ __ ] up like like give me like a big
scar or like something because I don't
want people to think like oh it's cool
Bob's in it blah blah blah it's like
that's definitely what we were doing I
mean it was definitely like look Bob
Odenkirk is in the movies but we gave
him a giant scar you can still tell it's
Bob owner I love that he got involved I
thought guys go soon so to wrap it up
here I am curious because of what you're
doing here is there any like like
traditional big budget Studio superhero
movie out there that's breaking the mold
in a way that you find creatively
exciting and wish more movies on that
scale would do to you know change the
industry and change the genre for the
better going forward
I like the suicide squad uh you know
that was fun morbius of course internet
I mean yeah that's the key word that's
partially I mean like I don't want to
put because like I do think Todd
Phillips Joker I loved it like it really
did inspire me it spoke to me in a way
that was like it's really cool that
there's a movie a comic book movie a
little loan one that makes a billion
dollars about like mental illness and
poverty and like where that all
intersects but like I think part of the
the thing with this movie is like I want
to see big budget IPS get the kind of
treatment that you're talking about
where
you know because it is such it is such a
wonderful genre that you can play in and
I feel like we really along the way
realized like you can do anything in
this world so like why can't you unpack
like real human emotion and themes and
stuff so I mean hopefully we have an
answer the next time we're asked that
question because I I don't really have
one right now I don't think I I can
understand I mean you're you're maybe
creating an answer with your own movie
and hopefully inspiring others out there
that way no I'm I'm fully like plea like
I'm I can't wait to see a major Studio
try to rip this off in some way it's
gonna be really funny to watch I am
counting down the seconds until I can
see that happen oh wow you know what I
will say is that if there are people in
positions of power in studios who are
willing to just say yes to stuff then I
think something like this is possible on
a much larger scale yeah because we had
nobody telling us no and I think that's
why it wound up the way that it did and
I also think I mean look I I'm so tired
of hearing people people say like the
world's ending in cinemas ending and all
that stuff like I do feel like it's like
we're kind of almost like at a starting
over point so like I don't know I have
hope for that I really do have hope for
that sorry you were trying to get rid of
us
I'm definitely not trying to I'm
terrible at keeping everybody on
schedule because I could talk about
these movies including you know ours all
day long congratulations this is a
serious feat that only gets accomplished
if people are so driven by what they
want to achieve so it is an absolute
Marvel huh I didn't mean to do that but
it truly is like a Marvel that all of
you came together and pulled this movie
off during such a challenging time so I
cannot congratulate you enough to
everybody out there keep an eye out for
the people's Joker and more interviews
from the supper Suite of Tiff 2022.